das internet hat alles was wir tun
verändert und es genauso ein teil
unseres lebens geworden wie essen und
trinken
es hat unsere interaktionen mit menschen
zu hause und überall auf der welt
revolutioniert und gestattet es
millionen von jedem ort aus unterwegs zu
arbeiten
nach unserem kaufverhalten und unserem
unterhaltungs konsum verändertes auch
die art wie wir bezahlen
es ebnete sogar einer neuen art des
geldes den weg den crypto währungen
was in treptow währungen wie verändern
sie unser leben und wir sind die
bedeutenden akteure dabei es ist an der
zeit die fakten aufzudecken und zu
ergründen wie internetgigant facebook
versucht crypto währungen zu
revolutionieren
eine der beliebtesten crypto währungen
die derzeit erhältlich sind ist
allgemein bekannt
bitcoin
bitcoin ist eine dezentrale
digitalisierung ohne zentralbank oder
zentrale verwaltung die über das
peer-to-peer bitcoin netzwerk ohne
mittelsmann zwischen nutzern verschickt
werden kann
transaktionen werden von netzwerkknoten
mittels kryptographie verifiziert und in
einem öffentlichen die central & leisure
der block chain verzeichnet bitcoin
wurde von einer unbekannten person oder
gruppe mit dem namen satori nakamoto
entwickelt und 2009 als quelloffene
software veröffentlicht
bitcoins sind die belohnung für das
sogenannte mining und können gegen an
regierungen produkte oder
dienstleistungen getauscht werden
forschungen der universität cambridge
ergaben dass 2017 schätzungsweise 2,9
bis 5,8 millionen benutzer crypto
währungsfonds nutzten die meisten davon
für bitcoin
bitcoin steht wegen seiner nutzung für
illegale geschäfte hohem stromverbrauch
preisschwankungen den diebstahl über
tauschbörsen und bei seriösen ökonomen
in der kritik die eine null preis
fordern
bitcoin ist auch eine investition
obwohl mehrere behörden im lauf der
jahre investoren vor der währung warnten
gehen wir nun zurück zum ursprung
am 18 august 2008 wurde der domainname
bitkom.org registriert am 31 oktober
2008 wurde ein link zu einem whitepaper
von satoshi nakamoto mit dem titel
bitcoin ein elektronisches papier cash
system über einen kryptographie mail
verteiler verbreitet nakamoto
entwickelte die bitcoins software als
quelloffenen code und veröffentlichte
sie im januar 2009 die identität
nakamoto es ist bis heute unbekannt
am dritten januar 2009 entstand das
bitcoin netzwerk als nakamoto den ersten
block der block chain meinte den genesis
blog die combase des blogs enthielt den
folgenden text wird heinz dritter januar
finanzministerium steht vor zweite
bankenrettung
es handelte sich um ein zitat aus der
new york times das als zeitangabe sowie
als kommentar zur instabilität des
mindestreserve bankwesens interpretiert
wurde
der empfänger der ersten bitcoin
transaktion war der cyberpunk helfen
erfinder des ersten wiederverwendbaren
proof of work systems rbo wie von 2004
sie lud die bitcoin software schon am
ersten tag herunter und erhielt er am 12
januar 2009 10 bitcoins von nakamoto
andere cyberpunk unterstützer erstellten
die vorläufer von bitcoin
fand wie manni und nix erschuf bit breit
2009 erfolgte die erste kommerzielle
zahlung mit bitcoins als der
programmierer laszlo hannes zwei pizzen
von papa john's für 10.000 depp colin
kaufte
schätzungen zufolge hat der nakamoto
eine million bitcoin gemeint bevor er
2010 spurlos verschwand und den netzwerk
waren schlüssel und die kontrolle des
code repository sun gewinn entrissen
übergab
entrissen wurde später leitender
entwickler bei der bitcoin foundation
und strebte die dezentralisierung der
kontrolle an was zu kontroversen über
die richtung der zukünftigen entwicklung
von bitcoin führte da die autorität
nakamoto es durch seine rolle bei der
entwicklung fehlte
nach den ersten machbarkeits nachweisen
waren die ersten großen benutzer von
bitkom schwarzmärkte wie die silk road
wären ihrem 30 monatigen bestehen seit
februar 2011 akzeptierte die plattform
ausschließlich bitcoin zahlungen und
setzte 9,9 millionen bitcoin im wert von
damals
214 millionen dollar
2011 betrug der wert anfangs 0,3 dollar
pro pack 1 was bis jahresende auf 5
dollar 27 gestiegen war am 8 juni des
gleichen jahres betrug der preis 31
dollar 50 innerhalb eines monats fiel
der preis wieder auf 11 dollar im monat
darauf auf 7 dollar 80 und dann weiter
auf 4 dollar 77
2012 betrug der anfangswert von bitcoin
fünf dollar 27 was bis jahresende auf 13
$ 30 stieg am 9 januar betrug der preis
schon sieben dollar 38 stürzte dann
jedoch in 16 tagen 49 prozent auf 3
dollar 80 ab
der preis stieg zum 17 august auf 16
dollar 41 fiel dann jedoch in drei tagen
um 57 prozent auf 7 dollar ziehen
im september 2012 wurde die bitcoin
foundation gegründet um die entwicklung
und nutzung von bitcoins zu fördern
2013 beträgt der preis anfangs 13 $ 30
und stieg bis zum ersten januar 2014 auf
770 dollar im märz 2013 spaltete sich
die block chain aufgrund eines fehlers
in version 0.8 der bitcoin software
zeitweise in zwei unabhängige strenge
mit verschiedenen regeln beide blog
chains liefen sechs stunden lang
parallel mit verschiedenen transaktions
aufzeichnungen seit dem zeitpunkt der
spaltung
als die mehrheit des netzwerks zu
version 0.7 und zur abwärts kompatiblen
version der block chain zurückkehrte
begann wieder der normalbetrieb
so wurde diese blog changer längsten
bestehenden die von allen teilnehmern
ungeachtet ihrer version der bitcoin
software genutzt werden konnte während
der spaltung stoppte die börse mount box
kurzzeitig den zahlungsverkehr wodurch
der preis um 23 prozent auf 37 dollar
fiel und sich in den anschließenden
stunden wieder auf etwa 48 dollar
stabilisierte die us
finanzaufsichtsbehörde finstern legt die
richtlinien für die zentrale virtuelle
währungen wie bitkom fest
amerikanische bitcoin meiner wurden
dadurch zu finanzdienstleistern erklärt
die eine registrierung brauchen und
rechtliche rahmenbedingungen erfüllen
müssen
im april kam es bei den bitcoin börsen
mit instant und mauern box zu
verzögerungen der abläufe durch
überlastung worauf der bitcoin preis von
266 dollar auf 76 dollar fiel und sich
nach sechs stunden wieder auf 160 dollar
erholte
am 10 april stieg der preis auf
259 dollar fiel dann jedoch in drei
tagen wieder um 83 prozent auf 45 dollar
am 15 mai 2013 beschlagnahmten
us-behörden die konten von mount cox da
sich die börse bei fenstern nicht als
finanzdienstleister registriert hatte
und am 23 juni 2013 beschlagnahmte die
us rauschgift behörde die
11,02 bitcoin im rahmen einer
beschlagnahmung maßnahme des
justizministeriums bezüglich 21 usd 881
[Musik]
dadurch beschlagnahmte zum ersten mal
eine regierungsbehörde bitcoin im
oktober 2013 beschlagnahmte das fbi etwa
30.000 bitcoin von der tag nicht website
silkroad bei der verhaftung von ross
william ulbricht
diese bitcoin wurden bei einer auktion
an den risikokapital investor day trader
versteigert
am 19 november stieg der bitcoin preis
auf 755 dollar und brach am selben tag
um 50 prozent auf 378 dollar ein am 30
november 2013 kletterte der preis auf
1.163 dollar bevor er langfristig bis
januar 2015 zusammenbrach und um 87
prozent auf
152 dollar abrutschte
am 5 dezember 2013 verbot die
chinesische volksbank chinesischen
geldinstituten die verwendung von
bitcoin in folge der ankündigung fiel
der bitcoin preis und baidu nahm für
manche dienste keine bitcoin an
der kauf realer waren mit virtuellen
währungen war in china mindestens seit
2009 verboten
2014 betrug der preis anfangs 770 dollar
und fiel im lauf des jahres auf 314
dollar
am 30 juli 2014 begann die wikimedia
stiftung damit spenden in bitcoin
anzunehmen
2015 betrug der preis anfangs 314 dollar
und stieg bis jahresende auf 434 dollar
2016 stieg der preis auf 998 dollar am
ersten januar 2017
2017 betrug der preis anfangs 998 dollar
und stieg bis zum ersten januar 2018 auf
13.400 12 dollar 44 nachdem am 17
dezember 2017 der höchststand von 19
1783 dollar rund sechs cent erreicht
worden war
china vollzog im september 2017 erste
schritte in richtung eines verbots des
handels mit bitcoin und verbot bitcoin
am ersten februar 2018 fällig die
bitcoin preise fielen von 9000 52 dollar
bis zum 5 februar 2018 auf
6914 dollar
der anteil des bitkom handels in der
chinesischen renminbi fiel von über 90
prozent im september 2017 auf weniger
als 1 prozent im juni 2018
während der ersten hälfte von 2010
schwankte der preis zwischen 11 1480 und
am ersten juli 2018 betrug der bitcoin
preis
6400 43 dollar
am ersten januar 2009 10 betrug der wert
1747 dollar 72 prozent weniger als am
anfang von 2018 und 81 prozent unter dem
damaligen rekordwert
[Musik]
bitcoin preise litten unter mehreren
hecking angriffen und diebstählen von
crypto währungs börsen wie dem diebstahl
bei check im januar 2018 kontroll und
bitkom im juni und banker im juli
in der ersten hälfte von 2018 wurde
crypto währung im wert von 761 millionen
dollar aus börsen gestohlen
obwohl von cornwall und banker andere
crypto währungen gestohlen worden waren
traf es den wert von bitcoin da
investoren sich um die sicherheit von
crypto währungs börsen sagten bitcoin
transaktionen werden mittels einer fonds
ähnlichen programmiersprache definiert
verschickt ein benutzer bitcoins gibt er
alle adressen und die jeweils zu senden
den bitcoins in einer ausgabe an
um double spending zu vermeiden muss
sich jede eingabe auf eine
vorangegangene nicht verwendete ausgabe
in der block chain beziehen die nutzung
mehrere eingaben ist vergleichbar mit
der verwendung mehrerer münzen bargeld
zahlungen da eine transaktion mehrere
ausgaben haben kann können benutzer geld
an mehrere parteien gleichzeitig senden
wie bei bargeld kann die menge der
eingaben der bitcoins größer sein als
die gewünschte menge der ausgaben
in diesem fall kommt eine zusatzaufgabe
zum einsatz und gibt dem zahler sein
wechselgeld
satt ossis die bald keine ausgabe
verwendung finden werden als
transaktionsgebühr verbucht
zwar sind transaktionsgebühren optional
jedoch können meiner transaktionen mit
höheren gebühren priorisieren und zuerst
bearbeiten sie können auch anhand der
transaktionsgebühr im verhältnis zum
speichervolumen auswählen nicht nur
anhand des reinen gebühren betrags diese
gebühren werden oft in satow skis pro
byd gemessen die transaktionsgröße hängt
von der anzahl der eingaben und der
anzahl der ausgaben hat
über die jahre haben bitcoin und crypto
währungen die gesellschaft stark
beeinflusst die begeisterung für crypto
währungen gewinnt online wie in der
praxis weiterhin an schwung es war nur
eine frage der zeit bis sich bestehende
online giganten mit einschalten würden
darunter auch der wohl größte überhaupt
facebook
facebook incorporated ist ein
amerikanisches online social networking
unternehmen aus menlo park kalifornien
es wurde von mark zuckerberg gegründet
gemeinsam mit seinem harvard
kommilitonen eduardo saverin andrew mc g
das den maske witz und chris hughes
facebook gilt als eine der vier
technologieriesen gemeinsam mit amazon
apple und google
anfangs war die mitgliedschaft auch
studenten aus harvard und später auch
columbia stanford und yale begrenzt
die mitgliedschaft wurde später auf die
verbleibenden ivy league schulen dass er
mit hochschulen und boston diverse
andere hochschulen sowie schließlich
sekundarschulen ausgeweitet
seit 2006 kann jeder der angibt älter
als 13 jahre zu sein sich bei facebook
registrieren
dies kann aufgrund lokaler gesetze
abweichen
der name rührt von den facebook
directory sehr die amerikanische
universität studenten oft erhalten im
februar 2012 veranstaltete facebook
seinen ersten börsengang mit einem
firmenwert von 104 milliarden dollar dem
bis dato höchsten einstiegs wert neu
eingetragenen firma
facebook macht den großteil seines
umsatzes durch werbeeinnahmen die
nutzern in ihrem newsfeed angezeigt
werden
facebook wird über geräte mit
internetanschluss genutzt wie zum
beispiel computer tablets und
smartphones
nach der registrierung erstellen die
nutzer ein profil und machen dabei
angaben zu sich selbst sie können texte
bilder und andere medien veröffentlichen
und mit allen nutzern teilen die einer
freundschaft zugestimmt haben nutzer
können auch eingebettete apps verwenden
interessen gruppen beitreten und updates
zu aktivitäten ihrer freunde erhalten
im dezember 2018 gab facebook an man
hätte über 2,3 milliarden aktive nutzer
im monat
gefälschte konnten sind jedoch ein
großes problem drei milliarden würden
bereits erkannt doch diejenigen die
unerkannt bleiben sind das wahre problem
kritiker stellen in frage ob facebook
seine tatsächliche nutzerzahl wirklich
kennt
facebook ist eines der wertvollsten
unternehmen der welt und erscheint oft
in den medien oft auch kontrovers
oft geht es um datenschutz und
privatsphäre wie im fall des cambridge
politiker skandals politische
einflussnahme wie bei der wahl 2016
psychologische effekte wie sucht
störungen und geringe selbstachtung
sowie inhalte die manche nutzer anstößig
finden die fake news
verschwörungstheorien und
urheberrechtsverstöße
dass facebook zudem keine
falschinformationen von seinen seiten
entfernt sorgt fortwährend für
kontroversen der vorwurf lautet facebook
verbreite falschinformationen und fake
news
facebook bietet auch andere produkte und
dienstleistungen er war unter anderem
instagram
watchers und großteil und entwickelte
eigenständig facebook messenger facebook
watch und facebook portal
zuckerberg entwickelte 2003 ihren seinem
studium in harvard zunächst die website
facemash die seite funktionierte wie hot
or not und verwendete online verfügbare
bilder der facebooks der neuen studenten
wohnhäuser
es wurden immer zwei nebeneinander
angezeigt und der nutzer sollte die
heißere person auswählen
facemash wurde in den ersten vier
stunden
450 mal besucht und die bilder 22.000
mal angesehen die seite fand ihren weg
zu verschiedenen gruppen servern des
campus wurde jedoch von der
hochschulleitung nach wenigen tagen
abgeschaltet sascha berg drohte der
rauswurf ihm wurden sicherheits
urheberrechts und privatsphäre verstöße
vorgeworfen
letztendlich wurden die vorwürfe
fallengelassen
sascha burger schuf aufbauend auf dem
projekt als vorbereitung für eine
kunstgeschichte prüfung ein tool zum
gemeinschaftlichen lernen er lud alle
kunstwerke auf einer webseite hoch wo
jedes eine kommentar sektion hatte und
teilte die seite mit seinen kommilitonen
ein facebook ist ein studenten register
mit bildern und persönlichen daten
2003 gab es in harvard nur eine
papierversion und private online
verzeichnisse
zuckerberg sagte der studentenzeitung
von herbert die rede ist oft von einem
allgemeinen facebook für harvard es ist
schon lächerlich dass die universität
jahre braucht um es umzusetzen
ich kann das besser als sie und brauche
dafür nur eine woche
im januar 2004 schrieb zuckerberg den
code einer neuen website die in
anlehnung an ein editorial der
studentenzeitung zu facemash la facebook
taufte er sagte die technologie für eine
zentrale website ist offensichtlich frei
verfügbar und bietet viele vorteile
sascha berg traf sich mit harvard
student etwa durch severin und sie
einigten sich je 1000 dollar in die
seite zu investieren
am 14 februar 2004 ging facebook online
anfangs unter facebook.com
sechs tage danach warfen die harvard
studenten cameron und tyler winklevoss
sowie die vienna randersacker berg vor
er habe ihnen irreführender weise
versprochen ihnen bei der entwicklung
eines sozialen netzwerks namen smart
connection backt raum zu helfen
sie sagten er benutze stattdessen ihre
ideen um ein konkurrenzprodukt zu
entwickeln sie wandten sich an die
studentenzeitung die eine untersuchung
bekannt
später verklagte die zuckerberg der
streit wurde 2008 für 1,2 millionen
anteile beigelegt die beim börsengang
facebooks 300 millionen dollar wert
waren
anfangs konnten nur mitglieder von haver
teilnehmern innerhalb weniger monate war
die hälfte der studenten beigetreten
das den moskovitz android colin von
chris hughes verwalteten mit zuckerberg
das wachstum der seite im märz 2004
expandierte facebook nach columbia
stanford yale und allen anderen eigenen
league hochschulen der boston university
der new york university die im m und
schließlich zu fast allen universitäten
in den usa und kanada
mitte des jahres 2004 wurde sean parker
einer der erfinder von napster und
berater sascha brox präsident von
facebook
im juni zog die firma nach palo alto in
kalifornien um wo sie noch im gleichen
monat die erste investition des paypal
mitbegründers peter fiehl erhielt
2005 strich das unternehmen nach dem
erwerb der internetadresse facebook.com
für 200.000 dollar das wird aus dem
namen
die adresse hatte erbaut face
corporation gehört
bis mai 2005 hatten mehrere partner 12,7
millionen dollar in facebook investiert
jim breyer steuerte eine weitere million
bei
im september 2005 erschien eine
highschool version der seite zudem
konnten mitarbeiter verschiedener firmen
beitreten darunter auch apple und
microsoft
am 26 september 2006 öffnete facebook
die pforten für alle die älter als 13
jahre waren und eine gültige
e-mail-adresse hatten gegen ende 2007
gab es 100.000 seiten auf facebook auf
denen firmen werbung machten
im mai 2009 kam in organisations seiten
hinzu
am 24 oktober 2007 gab microsoft bekannt
man habe 1,6 prozent von facebook für
240 millionen dollar angekauft
wodurch der geschätzte wert von facebook
auf 15 milliarden dollar stieg
microsofts ankauf enthielt das recht für
internationale werbung
im oktober 2008 verkündete facebook die
internationale zentrale stünde im
irischen dublin
im september 2009 erklärte facebook zum
ersten mai gewinn zu machen
eine studie von compete dot com vom
januar 2009 zufolge war facebook das
meistverwendete soziale netzwerk des
landes nach monatlich aktiven nutzern im
juli 2010 berichtete facebook man habe
500 millionen nutzer die hälfte der
mitglieder nutzten die seite täglich
durchschnittlich für 34 minuten
150 millionen nutzer nutzen die seite
über mobilgeräte
ein firmenvertreter nannte den
meilenstein eine stille revolution
im november 2010 betrug der wert von
facebook laut der privat börse second
marketing 41 milliarden dollar
das unternehmen hatte ebay überholt und
war nun das tritt der us internet
unternehmen nach google und amazon
am 15 november 2010 verlautete facebook
man habe die domain fd.com für eine
nicht näher genannte summe von der
amerikanischen fargo federation gekauft
am 11 januar 2011 meldete farm bureau
einnahmen aus den verkäufen in höhe von
8,5 millionen dollar wodurch der kauf
von fd.com einer der zehn teuersten
domainverkäufe aller zeiten wurde
im februar 2011 kündigte facebook an man
plane einen umzug auf den ehemaligen
campus von sun microsystems dem
kalifornischen menlo park im
märz wurde bekannt dass facebook zur
verbesserung der cyber-sicherheit
täglich etwa 20.000 profile aufgrund von
verstößen wie es bei grafischen inhalten
und verwendung durch minderjährige
löschte
im juni 2011 erreichte facebook eine
million seitenaufrufe und wurde die
meistbesuchte bei doubleclick
registrierte website
laut einer neuen erhebung wurde facebook
2011 zur am zweithäufigsten gesuchten
webseite nach google
im märz 2011 kündigte facebook den
webseiten basierten app store app center
an der
store sollte auf iphones und android
geräten sowie in der mobilen web version
verfügbar sein im april 2012 kaufte
facebook instagram für etwa eine
milliarde dollar in bargeld und aktien
am 17 mai folgte der börsengang
facebooks mit einem aktienpreis von 38
dollar
der firmenwert wurde auf 104 milliarden
dollar geschätzt dem zur damaligen zeit
höchsten wert
der börsengang brachte 16 milliarden
dollar ein und belegte somit platz drei
hinter visa inc 2008 und weil es im jahr
auf basis des jahresumsatzes von 2012
von 5 milliarden dollar wurde facebook
im mai 2013 teil der fortune 500 auf
platz 4 162
nie zuvor wurden bei einem börsengang
mehr aktien gehandelt
46 millionen
der börsengang geriet aufgrund des
raschen kurssturzes in die kritik und
kam auch vor gericht
eigenuntersuchungen
saarburg verkündete im oktober 2012
facebook habe monatlich eine milliarde
aktiver nutzer 600 millionen davon auf
mobilgeräten sowie
219 milliarden hochgeladene bilder und
140 milliarden freundschafts
verbindungen am 12 april 2016 stellte
zuckerberg seine vision für die nächsten
zehn jahre vor die sich auf drei säulen
stütze
künstliche intelligenz verbesserte
globale vernetzung sowie virtuelle und
orientiert realität im juni stellte
facebook die text vor eine kita
verarbeitung natürlicher sprache die in
20 sprachen intentionen und kontext
erlernen und erfassen können sascha
brack und seine firma hat einen großen
erfolg doch es sollte nicht lange dauern
dass einige diese großartige technologie
für ihre eigenen ziele zweckentfremdeten
die kontroverse stand kurz bevor
am 28 september 2008 10 kam es bei
facebook zu einer großen
sicherheitslücke welche die daten von 50
millionen nutzern betraf die
sicherheitslücke trat im juli 2017 auf
und wurde am 16 september entdeckt
facebook verständigte die betroffenen
nutzer und sperrte ihre konten
im märz 2009 10 erklärte facebooks die
passwörter von millionen von facebook
lite nutzern seien kompromittiert worden
im april fügte das unternehmen hinzu
dass nicht nur facebook betroffen war
sondern auch millionen von instagram
nutzern
die passwörter waren als einfacher
unverschlüsselter text gespeichert
worden und konnten so von mitarbeitern
ausgelesen werden
entschuldigungen von facebook fanden
sich in zeitungen im fernsehen in blogs
und auf facebook am 25 märz 2018
veröffentlichten große amerikanische und
britische zeitungen ganzseitige
entschuldigungen von mark zuckerberg
entschuldigte sich mündlich auf cnn
im mai 2010 entschuldigte er sich für
unregelmäßigkeiten bei der privatsphäre
zuvor war die privatsphäre einstellungen
auf 20 seiten verteilt nun fanden sich
alle auf einer wodurch es für apps von
drittanbietern schwieriger war auf
persönliche daten zuzugreifen
zusätzlich zur entschuldigung kündigte
facebook die überprüfung tausende apps
an die verdächtiges verhalten gezeigt
hatten um erneuten datenschutzproblemen
vorzubeugen
ein bericht von 2010 zum datenschutz kam
zu dem schluss dass nur wenig über die
folgen online veröffentlichte
persönlicher informationen bekannt sei
oft seien also nur berichte verfügbar
die durchgängige medien verbreitung
fanden
2017 sagte ein ehemaliges
vorstandsmitglied von facebook die
sozialen medien tragen zur zersetzung
des gesellschaftlichen gefüges bei
facebook ist auf beiträge von nutzern
angewiesen um alle nutzer an den dienst
zu binden die plattform stand in der
kritik da anstößige inhalte wie
verschwörungstheorien und soziale
randerscheinungen toleriert würden
während andere inhalte als unangemessen
eingestuft wurden
facebook wurde als vektor für fake news
bezeichnet und sei verantwortlich für
die verschwörungstheorie die usa haben
den usa schaffen falsche an tiere hinter
meldungen mit denen das militär mir ein
maß völkermord rechtfertigte
verschwörungstheorien bezüglich des andy
hug massakers sowie attacken auf
flüchtlinge in deutschland
die regierung der philippinen nutzte
facebook zudem um kritiker anzugreifen
facebook hat seine inhalts richtlinien
mehrfach angepasst im juli 2018 wurde
verkündet man würde artikel die von
fakten checken als falsch eingestuft
wurden herabstufen und fehlinformationen
die gewalt beförderten entfernen
zuckerberg entschuldigte sich für eine
aussage es sei unklar ob holocaust
leugner tatsächlich andere irre führen
wollten
facebook gibt an als falsch gemeldeten
inhalte würden die monetarisiert und er
führen deutlich geringere verbreitung
beiträge die gegen die community
richtlinien verstoßen können von
facebook gelöscht werden
im mai 2009 10 verbannte facebook eine
reihe gefährlicher kommentatoren von
seiner plattform darunter alex jones
louis fahren kann melilla napoli joseph
watson
david und laura luna da diese angeblich
gewalt und hass verbreiteten
2018 klagte der sonderberater robert
müller 13 russische staat und drei
russische organisationen an regen
operationen zur störung amerikanischer
politik und wahl prozesse einschließlich
der präsidentschaftswahl 2016
müller wandte sich anschließend an
facebook da im vorfeld der
präsidentschaftswahl 2016 werbung im
wert von 100.000 dollar an eine internet
forschungsagentur mit verbindungen zum
russischen geheimdienst verkauft worden
war
im september 2017 teilte der chief
security officer von facebook alex de
moz mit man habe etwa 100.000 dollar an
werbeausgaben zwischen juni 2015 und
2017 gefunden die zu 3000 werbungen
gehörten und in verbindung mit 470
gefälschten konnten standen die gegen
die richtlinien verstießen
analysen hätten ergeben es gebe einen
zusammenhang zwischen den konten und
seiten und sie würden von russland aus
kontrolliert die kampagnen von trump und
klienten gaben 81 millionen dollar für
werbung auf facebook aus das unternehmen
sagte der untersuchung von robert julia
volle kooperation zu und legte alle
informationen zur russischen werbung
offen einschließlich der identitäten der
personen und firmen hinter den käufen
angehörige der geheimdienst gremien des
repräsentantenhauses und des senats
warfen facebook vor wichtige
informationen hierzu zurückzuhalten
russische agenten nutzten facebook um
black live meter sowie immigrations
feindliche demonstration in amerika zu
organisieren ebenso wie veranstaltungen
gegen hillary clinton sowie für und
gegen donald trump
facebook werbung wurde zudem verwendet
um spaltungen bezüglich politischen
aktivismus von afro amerikanern und
muslimen zu verstärken in dem
verschiedene personen ihren ansichten
und neigungen entsprechend
widersprüchliche mitteilungen erhielten
teilweise gaben die akteure sich hierzu
als andere personen aus
mark zuckerberg drückte sein bedauern
aus er habe die bedenken bezüglich einer
einmischung russlands in die wahl 2016
nicht ernst genommen
im januar 2019 entfernte facebook 2 189
seiten und 75 koordinierte konnten die
zur staatlichen russischen
nachrichtenagentur sputnik gehörten und
sich fälschlicherweise als unabhängige
nachrichten quellen oder allgemeine
seiten ausgegeben hatten
insgesamt hatten die seiten
790.000 verlor und hatten zwischen
oktober 2013 und januar 2009 10
135.000 dollar für werbung ausgegeben
facebook entfernte später nochmals
1907 konnten mit verbindungen nach
russland die an koordinierten
authentischen verhalten beteiligt waren
2018 kritisierte ein bericht des
britischen die cms facebooks mangelnde
aufklärung des missbrauchs der
plattformen durch russische behörden und
dass das problem herunter gespielt werde
keiner dieser zwischenfälle konnte
diesen gewaltigen unternehmen
langfristig schaden und facebooks
zukunft ist vielversprechend
über die jahre wurden facebook
liederbücher filme und fernsehserien
gewidmet der film the social network von
2010 von david fincher und aaron sorkin
mit jesse eisenberg als mark zuckerberg
gewann drei oscars und vier golden
globes
2008 erklärte dass collins dictionary
facebook zum neuen wort des jahres
im dezember 2009 erklärte das oxford
american dictionary das wort an trend
zum wort des jahres es bedeutet jemanden
in einem sozialen netzwerk wie facebook
von der freundesliste zu streichen
im august 2013 gründete facebook
gemeinsam mit sechs anderen
technologieunternehmen internet dort um
erschwinglichen und verlässlichen
internetzugang für entwicklungsländer zu
ermöglichen man wollte den teilen der
welt internetzugang und die vorteile der
vernetzung ermöglichen in denen diese
bislang fehlten
verdienst fried basics enthält
grundlegende anwendungen mit geringem
datenverbrauch
accuweather baby center bbc news espn
und die suchmaschine bing
2018 sagte mark zuckerberg internet dot
org habe bereits 100 millionen menschen
den internetzugang ermöglicht die sonst
vielleicht keinen zugang hätten
fri basics ist in dutzenden ländern
verfügbar
da das erbe gefestigt und die zukunft
vielversprechend war wandte sich
facebook den crypto währungen zu
im mai 2009 10 gründete facebook libra
networks angeblich um eine eigene
stabile crypto währung zu entwickeln
vor kurzem wurde berichtet große
finanzinstitutionen wie visa mastercard
und paypal sowie über stünden hinter
libra
die firmen wollen jeweils angeblich 10
millionen dollar in die veröffentlichung
der krypto währung libra investieren
die krypto währung libra der social
media unternehmens basiert auf einer
thermischen flaggschiff
projekt währung und transaktionen sollen
von der libra association verwaltet
werden einem teil der facebook tochter
calibra sowie 27 weiteren firmen aus
zahlungsweisen technologie
telekommunikation onlinehandel
risikokapital unten und prof
stand juli 2009 10 existieren weder die
währung noch das netzwerk bislang gibt
es nur rudimentären experimentellen code
die veröffentlichung sollte 2020
stattfinden
der vizepräsident von facebook david
haye markus wechselte im mai 2018 von
facebook messenger zu einer neuen blog
chain abteilung kurz darauf gab es erste
berichte facebook plane eine crypto
währung unter merkels führung
im februar 2009 10 arbeiteten mehr als
50 techniker an dem projekt
2009/10 bestätigten sich vermutungen
bezüglich der krypto währung facebooks
damals noch global crown oder facebook
kein genannt
am 15 juli 2009 10 gab facebook bekannt
die viren würde erst veröffentlicht wenn
alle behördlichen bedenken ausgeräumt
sind und lieber entsprechende
genehmigungen hat
libra sollte durch finanzwerte wie einen
währungskorb und us-staatsanleihen
gedeckt sein um instabilität zu
vermeiden
facebook kündigte an jeder der partner
würde anfangs zehn millionen dollar
investieren damit libra vom ersten tag
an gedeckt sein
libra partner innerhalb der liebe
association würden bei bedarf neue libra
währungseinheit mehr stellen bibra
einheiten die im konventionellen
währungen ausgezahlt wurden würden
ausgemustert
der anfängliche abgleich von
transaktionen würde von allen partnern
ausgeführt und diese wiederum über einen
dezentralen ledger abgeglichen
so sollte niemand außer der liebe
association daten des dezentralen
ledgers auslesen und analysieren können
regierungen wie bitcoins nutzen eine
offene blog chain libra wiederum ist
nicht die zentrale und erfordert ein
vertrauen in die liebe association als
de facto zentralbank
facebook hatte zuvor mit 27 anderen in
genf die libra association gegründet um
die währung zu überwachen
das projekt wird von zentralbanken
kritisiert die implementierung mittels
crypto währung und log 10 wurde hierbei
in frage gestellt
us behörden und politiker äußerten bei
der ankündigung 219 bedenken
maxine waters vorsitzende des
finanzausschusses im repräsentantenhaus
bad facebook die entwicklung und
veröffentlichung von libera auszusetzen
als grund nannte sie eine reihe skandale
und sagte dass die im crypto
währungsmarkt ein rechtlicher rahmen
viele
der finanzausschuss des
repräsentantenhauses
forderte facebook in einem brief auf die
entwicklung wegen datenschutz
sicherheits handels und
finanzpolitischen bedenken einzustellen
vorsitzender der federal reserve sagte
am 10 juli 2009 10 vor dem kongress die
zentralbank habe ernste bedenken
bezüglich des umgangs von libra mit
geldwäsche verbraucherschutz und
finanzstabilität
der damalige präsident tram steht am 12
juli auf twitter facebook müsse sich dem
bankwesen unterordnen und alle
regelungen einhalten wenn sie eine bank
werden wollten
der finanzminister frankreichs bruno le
maire sagte im französischen radio libra
könne keinesfalls eine eigenständige
währung werden und wie ist das parlament
auf bedenken zu datenschutz geldwäsche
und terrorismusfinanzierung bei libra
hin er bat die leiter der zentralbanken
der g7 einem gericht zu facebooks plänen
anzufertigen
der leiter der bank of england mag ali
sagte man müsse neuen
zahlungstechnologien gegenüber offen
sein jedoch müsse sich alles innerhalb
der finanzwelt in das system einfügen
und höchste standards vision
der deutsche abgeordnete markus ferber
warnte davor facebook könne eine
schatten bank werden die regierung
japans startete eine untersuchung die
brass sowie eine analyse ihrer
auswirkungen auf die japanische
finanzpolitik
dies sollte vor dem g7-treffen vom 24
bis 26 august 2009 10 abgeschlossen sein
der datenschutzbeauftragte der schweiz
der laut david marques den datenschutz
von libro beaufsichtigen sollte gab an
noch nicht von facebook kontaktiert
worden zu sein
branchenexperten sind sich uneins ob
liga den nutzern datenschutz bieten kann
facebook plant die verwaltung von bebra
für facebook-nutzer der tochter calibra
zu überlassen und betonte dass calibra
die consumer in der kontoinhaber nicht
ohne einwilligung mit facebook teilen
wird
das system soll jedoch auch eine
suchfunktion für freunde enthalten
welches calibra gestatten soll den
transaktions verlauf des kontoinhabers
mit seinem facebook-konto zu verknüpfen
lieber wird nicht auf meinen setzen
nur mitglieder der libro association
können transaktionen innerhalb der
thermischen blog chain verarbeiten
bebra plant innerhalb von fünf jahren
den umstieg auf ein offenes proof of
work system gibt jedoch auch zu
verstehen es gebe aktuell keine lösung
die zitat in ausreichendem maß
stabilität und sicherheit für milliarden
von menschen und ihre transaktionen auf
der ganzen welt in einem offenen
netzwerk bieten könnte
der quellcode von libre wurde in rast
geschrieben und quelloffen mit einer
apache-lizenz am 18 juni 2009 10
veröffentlicht
eine kolumnistin von bloomberg news
versuchte den veröffentlichten code von
libro zum laufen zu bringen
die veröffentlichte software konnte
lediglich gefälschte coins in einer welt
platzieren fast alle funktionen des
whitepapers fehlten einschließlich
größere architekturelemente die noch
nicht erfunden wurden
ich war überrascht dass facebook die
software in diesem zustand
veröffentlichte
facebook will 2020 eine digitale wallet
namens calibra veröffentlichen die über
facebook messenger whatsapp und auch
eigenständig erhältlich sein soll
die sprache der smart contrexx und
transaktionen von nebra heißt move und
soll in beit kombiniert werden
das ergebnis bleibt abzuwarten doch
aufgrund des erfolges von krippe
währungen und der starken
kommunikationsnetzwerke der social media
giganten stehen die erfolgschancen gut
solange die allgemeinheit weiter den
allgegenwärtigen gefällt mir -button
benutzt